do you guys remember that story I don't
know if it's true or not but it's a good
story this woman had a viral Tik Tok
where she explained a professor was
talking about capitalism and communism
and issued a wager to the students
saying we'll try out communism everybody
will take their final or their their
midterm or whatever and then we'll
average out the grades and give everyone
an equal grade and they and you know
bunch of people are like no no we don't
do that bunch of people are like yeah
okay let's do it what end up happening
is the people who busted their asses and
studied and and Ma and you know hit the
nail with the hammer ended up getting
bees and the people who did barely
anything were like this is great I got a
bee then the people who did really well
and held the average high said what was
the point of doing all that work if I
ended up not even getting ahead because
of it I just wasted my time for no
reason so what happened the next time
they they ended up doing some you know
the next test that came around everyone
ended up getting a c now everyone's
pissed off and complaining about how
this is running and then the next test
everyone failed because everyone started
saying what's the point of working if
I'm not going to get ahead because of it
why would I why would I hurt myself and
and struggle and not be rewarded for it
and that's that's the problem of
Communism it's not so much I certainly
think there are marxists and Communists
who want to F the system but I think
when you look at what AOC represents
there is a banality of Communism there
is the blind ignorance of marching
towards communism by people who are too
stupid and to uh uh their first order
thinkers AOC for example I think she's
she she lies a I think that's evil but I
also think she's really stupid so what
ends up happening is what is she saying
now she signed on to a pledge from the
Democratic Socialist to raise they want
they want taxes raised on the top 5% of
New York and that's what and that's
where we're at 10 years ago it was the
1% now it's the 5% when there's no one
left to tax you have to tax every
everyone else it's easy to say the 1%
they raise the taxes now the 1% leaves
Revenue goes down the 5% then the 10
then the 20 then the 25 then the top 50%
then it's class war then it's just
people fleeing and you get open air drug
markets you get exactly what we're
seeing now and once the system breaks
they then come in and say give us
absolute control to solve this problem
we need to come in with strong military
force and security to clean up the
streets give us the power well and of
course the irony is that the more they
tax people once they hit that Revenue
maximizing Point uh in the laugher curve
and continue to go further which they I
would argue have long ago an increase in
taxes actually starts to result in less
Revenue in certain circumstances so when
things get really bad and they start
dipping lower and lower and say STP 10
top 10% top 20% Etc what happens is not
only do they start taking in less
Revenue because people leave the city or
they're they aren't working as hard or
more people lose their job or employers
can't afford to continue to higher
people then the government has less
revenue and more of that Revenue ends up
being spent on the corrupt bureaucrat
who are sabotaging the system and trying
to pull from it as much as they possi
can before it totally collapses so
people get a whole lot less people like
AOC they and these leftists they don't
understand how taxes work raising taxes
decreases tax revenue and if you're a
first order thinker not very bright you
go huh it's kind of like the people on
Twitter who are like uh food comes from
the store dude it's like no food comes
from a variety of places first there's a
farm then there is a distribution then
then there is packaging right it goes
through a lot of different phases before
finally makes it to your store but the
reason raising taxes typically will
decrease tax revenue if you have a
dollar and tax is 5 cents 5% and I give
someone the dollar they got to give a
nickel to the government but they still
have 95 cents so they trade that 95
cents and now someone's going to give
you know four 4.8 or whatever or
whatever the math is another fraction so
the government in these two transactions
ends up getting slightly more than the
one transaction the simple way it works
is if you tax someone at 50% % and then
someone trades their dollar you take
half of it then the next person only has
50 cents they can't afford to buy
anything so they sit on it the
government government made 50 cents if
the tax is lower everyone keeps trading
all the way around until they get down
to 50 cents and the government has taken
a slightly higher percentage so the the
the easiest way to explain this is the
story I was told was that there was a
Home Depot in Cook County Illinois that
shut down and reopened in DuPage County
uh like like 5 miles away and they spent
a couple million dollars to do this and
the reason was when the county raised
taxes by I think like. 2% or something
like .2% some tiny number if you're
talking about a fraction of a percent
but you're spending millions of dollars
on supplies and orders through Home
Depot for for your Contracting work you
can save a couple hundred bucks or a
couple thousand dollars you will drive a
couple miles per day to pick up your
supplies it doesn't matter that much so
what ends up happening is they raise
taxes trade drops off now the
government's getting a percent up 50% of
zero is zero mhm whereas 5% of a dollar
is is 5 cents you rather have the 5
cents but this is what they do this is
where we're going absolutely and I also
want to point something out here uh
about AOC Tim you mentioned that it's
what 200,000 or more per year 250 so 250
uh AOC uh makes what 175,000 a year and
she was complaining that it was
unacceptable that she had $177,000 in
student debt if you're making
$175,000 a year and you're a single
person you don't have children you don't
have dependant then you should be able
to handle $117,000 in debt right we're
talking
$175,000 a year that's a lot of
money bro come on okay she has a Tesla
you're right she got pay she has to pay
that off yeah no exactly so my point is
she can't afford this 177,000 a year
even though she makes or not 177,000 a
year 177,000 total in debt when she has
$175,000 coming in each year and she's
going to sit here and lecture us about
how people could be paying more money
for social programs that they didn't
sign up for when when she chose to take
that debt out herself I I will say to be
fair Teslas actually aren't that
expensive not as expensive as they used
to be yeah I think she's like a model 3
and it's like $30,000 which is crazy to
think because that's unacceptable that
she owes $330,000 on that crazy car it's
crazy that cars have gotten that
expensive the the the cost of cars is is
nuts right now it's great that Elon Musk
is dropping the prices of all the Teslas
repeatedly but uh it's crazy when you go
to dealerships and you see the inventory
is gone and the price is through the
roof
yeah they they they you're you'll live
in the Pod and you'll eat the bugs
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
delicious and I I I gen I really I don't
see how we avoid the living in the pot
and eating the bugs
thing yeah do you think only the rich
will eat meat is else nope I think
you're going to be at a restaurant and
uh you're going to be sitting there
talking with your friends and laughing
you're going to look over the menu and
you're going to say I'll do the I'll do
the bran Zeno and they're going to go
excellent choice sir and then they're
going to walk out with a plate full of
mashed roaches and they're going to put
it down you're go ah neuralink on the
fritz and you're going to flick it and
then it's goop and then you're going to
see the roaches turn into a Branzino so
you are actually so someone's going to
be like I I'll do the uh flowless
chocolate cake with the vanilla ice
cream excellent and they're going to
bring out cockroach mash and they're
going to put it in front of you and you
won't see that you will see chocolate
cake and you'll be you know eating it
like M oh it's so delicious and then
anybody without the norlink they're
going to see the roach legs smatter to
your face and like and the and the roach
Gunk on your face licking it off is
there any traction they don't even need
to go that far they don't even need to
go that far they get people to call men
women all the time they've just changed
our vernacular so much and put social
pressure on people to not disagree with
them they State obvious mistruths yeah
yeah yeah I got a bone to I got a bone
to pick with all of your vernaculars cuz
you guys have been saying theft wrong
this whole time okay and and and this
theft is so Insidious there's there's
property theft there's sales theft there
there's hotel theft there's so theft
going now that that it's abolutely
disgusting because it stops the free
market for one being free but also stops
individuals from solving problems and
being there for each other and
communities and robbing them of any
freedom back to the point uh I don't
think necessarily it'll be neuralink I
don't know I think if they get to the
point where neuralink can be Wireless
this will happen but uh my point
is right now uh the Taco Bell near me we
were we were flying back and we drove we
we were driving past Taco Bell and
Sheamus insisted that we live Moss I
said we have to live Moss right now over
we have to live Moss we did seed oil
gers guys guys calm down yes okay so
anyway we went there uh on another trip
we went inside not with Sheamus this
time and it was kiosks they were human
beings behind the counter but they're
just making food and you go to a kiosk
to
order give it 10 or 20 years you're
going to walk in a Taco Bell and it's
going to say uh you know you're going to
you're going to type in I'll do a Cheesy
gida crunch extra sauce checkout and
it's going to say neural pay and you're
going to be like uh there's nobody here
MH there's no humans I what's I don't
have neural pay I only have my credit
card on me and it's just going to say we
no longer accept credit cards at this
time you either get it or you don't I've
thought about something weirdly a lot
I'm curious for your guys' opinion on it
what happens to the adte world in a
fully saturated neuralink world in the
sense that you know like Google
AdWords totally changed the way search
happened on the internet because it all
became all about the word you're
searching for and you monetize the
specific words billions of dollars of
advertising go into bidding on words
when the interface moves from words to
thoughts it's like I can almost it's
still words though but I can imagine but
those are going to get tagged to
basically like neural activity and
you're going to signatures of neural
activity associated with those words
you're going to basically have like
bidding on neural signatures like very
directly I I think the bigger issue with
neuralink advertising is going to be the
discovery of uh uh we already know this
but the degrees of cognitive uh
faculties I suppose right the I don't
want to say IQ necessarily but there are
uh uh different different metrics by
which we uh uh assess an individual an
individual's brain capacity IQ being one
of them there's also visualization
examples the one where they show uh uh
they show an apple and they say when you
think of an apple what do you see yeah
and then the first one is a vivid
photorealistic Apple the next one is a
you know flat two-dimensional Apple the
next one is a black and white outline
and the next one is nothing and there
are a lot of people who have responded
to these saying like you can see an
apple when you think it man some people
can't some people report not having an
inner monologue and I've met people they
they say that they don't have an in mon
and I'm like so what do you think when
you think like if you're not thinking in
pictures words sounds and like
visualization what are you thinking and
they're like I don't know just thoughts
I guess what I've experienced in talking
to people about this is that some people
think in pictures some people think in
sounds some people think in images of
the words themselves and some people
report none of this some people in their
minds are talking to themselves as they
think and some people are not some
people have multi track minds and some
people don't so when it comes to
neuralink and they begin to try and
track your brain activity for ads it's
going to be interesting when they find
people who get into noral link they're
going to say and whether you want them
to or not these these AI companies these
big tech companies if if neuralink type
devices human brain inter brain computer
interfaces become ubiquitous they will
absolutely track your cognitive level
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net